hi Japan for the Justice League I'm Ben
Affleck I'm Jason Momoa I'm ray Fisher
and I'm flash fastest man alive in the
new movie Justice League we see the
evolution of a new Batman inspired by
Superman's sacrifice he's moved on from
lone vigilante to recruiter and leader
the others where are they
Wonder Woman has already established a
relationship with Batman in a way they
are a perfect match as partners the
flash got hit by a bolt of lightning
giving him superpowers which are
obviously extremely sweet Aquaman is the
heir to the throne of Atlantis
but resists that title and the
responsibility that comes with it cyborg
is totally unique as a digital and
physical tank and able to interface with
any form of Technology just a father
learn yourself food don't take it from
here
do I know you
we are we all justice the justices the
Justice League check out the trailer for
Justice League and don't forget to
follow the film on social see you in
cinemas this November
you